as the legality of the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act aka
Obamacare goes before the highest court
in the land here are three reasons to
chuck the whole program the supreme
court will issue its verdict later this
spring of course but there's no question
that if the government can force you to
do something simply because you exist
and draw breath then the American
experiment and limited government is
over and done with whether it's
mandating the eating of broccoli at
every meal or making people buy
insurance a government that can make you
do whatever it wants just eight in the
American grain the latest government
estimate of cost tells us what we
already knew this is going to cost us
much more than the arm and the leg it's
supposed to save us the Congressional
Budget Office is now saying that the
first full decade of Obamacare is going
to cost about 1.8 trillion dollars or
double the original estimate used to
sell the program
health insurance isn't the same thing as
health most of us might end up paying
more for insurance under Obamacare but
there's precious little evidence that
coverage itself leads to lower medical
costs a 1993 study by the RAND
Corporation found that for the average
person there were no substantial
benefits from free care not smoking
eating moderately and not boozing it up
provide greater health benefits than any
low deductible loko pay insurance plan
for reason TV i'm nick gillespie